back to this part of the world hundreds
of thousands of people are gathering in
London to call for a second referendum
on brexit organizers are hoping to
convince lawmakers to back a new public
vote on whether Britain should follow
through on plans to leave the European
Union the March is due to conclude
outside parliament which has so far
failed to agree on a formal exit deal
with the bloc earlier this week Prime
Minister Theresa May and EU leaders
agreed to postpone grete hoping to allow
Parliament time to pass a deal and in
London our correspondent Charlotte Potts
is standing by Charlotte what's going on
where you are so people have been
gathering here in central London
carrying European and UK flex basically
from all over the country 200 buses
arrived from the Scottish Highlands up
to Wales and from Cornwall and from all
London neighbourhoods organisers are
actually expecting up to 1 million
people joining this match - here in
London today and the number one demand
is of the protesters today that they are
demanding a second vote a second
referendum they want to put it back to
the people and they want to vote on
whether to accept Mays deal that she
negotiated in Brussels over the past
month or any kind of deal for that
matter and they want to vote on whether
the UK should actually indeed stay in
the European Union after all so the
model here today of the people that I've
talked to have been telling me stop the
brexit madness and that is on
everybody's mind people are angry at
politicians and the government for
wasting to two years with these
negotiations they are tired of the
political process and they are hoping
that a second referendum could be the
number one solution here we've all been
looking into crystal balls for months
now I'm going to ask you to do the same
in this moment how likely is a second
referendum to happen
well I mean certainly this March is
gonna send some visuals to Parliament
some strong images senior and peace from
the Labour Party are marching here next
to celebrities young and old people from
all walks of life also there is a
petition that is demanding to revoke
article 50 and for the UK to stay in the
European Union that has gained
incredible traction online over 4
million signatures so far so that is
hard to ignore but we also have to
remember that the UK is an absolute
political turmoil at the moment may has
just returned from Brussels the EU has
allowed to extend the deadline for the
UK leaving the European Union until
April 12th or even later if male May
gets her deal through Congress it's
through Parliament I'm sorry but the
problem is that that may might not even
put her deal before Parliament anymore
because she knows that as the chances
are so slim also within the Tory Party
criticism is rising against Theresa May
for her to step down as Prime Minister
so again there's no clear path forward
and so this is what protesters are
demanding today they are demanding a
second referendum and are hoping that
there will be the solution to the
political turmoil here in the UK
DW Charlotte plots in London for
Charlotte thanks so much